Here's one way to define factorial.
There are lots and lots of ways to solve this, so we're going to define
a procedure and its input is the number "n."
What we want to do is compute this function—we're going to compute
"n" times "n" minus one times "n" minus two.
We are going to need a variable to keep track of the results as we go,
as well as a variable to keep track of how many times we go.
We're going to define a procedure that computes the factorial of "n."
What we need to do is multiply all these numbers, so we're going to have
a variable that keeps track of the results so far.
We'll start by initializing that to one, so we'll call that "result" and we'll
set its initial value to one.
We're going to keep multiplying by "n" until we get to the end.
We're going to have our "while" loop where the test condition is as long as
"n" is greater than equal to one.
We're going to start with "n" as the value that was passed in.
We're going to subtract one each time we go through the loop
until we get down to one, and keep updating the result.
The result keeps updating, so we want the result to be the previous
result times "n."
We also have to change the value of "n" to keep reducing "n" as we go.
We subtract one from "n" every time through the loop.
The result is multiplied by the current value of "n"—"n" is decreased by one.
We keep going until we get to "n" is equal to one.
We're not quite done yet.
We want to return a "result," and the value that we want is stored
in this variable "result," so we "return results" here.
Let's try that in the Python interpreter.
Now we'll see what happens when we have the input 4—our child
playing with the blocks.
We see the results as 24.
They're 24 different ways to arrange the four blocks.
Factorials increase pretty quickly, so we could also use the factorial
procedure to figure out the number of different ways to arrange a deck
of playing cards.
If we have a deck with 50 cards, there are 52 ways to pick the first card,
51 ways to pick the second, and so forth.
When we run this, we see that the factorial of 52 is this really big number.
That's why you can have so many different card games.
Every time you play, the arrangement of the cards is going to be different.